is that all right if I get a picture
with everyone before we hang a picture
with everyone before they leave sure
yeah yeah well should we just get a
picture with everybody that came out
here should we do a big Marvel family
photo let's bring everybody back out I
think another way back now to Union here
yeah Jess they're all coming out madam
in the front row thank you oh my god
I feel like I just gave birth Benedict
[Applause]
joining us
[Applause]
really
[Applause]
by the way I want to thank our useful
guest Michael chiquinho where is he
Lester microcirculation gentleman from
useful guest all right thanks everyone
get it by the way everybody in this room
right now
here's what he says you're caught out
right now
but no push and shove everyone will get
one they're going to distribute them so
I'm gonna stand here like I love you
[Applause]
normal studio panel everyone huge hand
this was an incredible experience
thanks everyone thanks tomorrow thanks
Kevin
you